hi I'm Ryan I'm gonna be watching the  trailer for Paranormal Activity the  marked ones or better known as  paranormal with Mexicans come on Mexican  guy number three they just brush that  off there's a bike [ __ ] it good thing  you're recording your friend doing a  host [ __ ] why was he recording that  that's Katie that's Christine your  seminar so because that's Chrissy taking  the ones that are marked they because oh  it's tying it in clever she's hot I like  that girl  oh [ __ ] Oh where'd he go he's gonna be  next time  predictable well you'd be great at patty  Kate I don't I don't speak Spanish you  okay and it was pretty scary kind of  wish I didn't live alone cool one of the  thumbnails appearing on YouTube is a  girl who's blonde with really big boobs